[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Jenna basako
responsable de l'antenne toi et moi
nord-ouest Île-de-France bonjour bonjour
alors toi et moi est une toi à moi
pardon est une association qui date de
2007 et qui émane de Denis Castin et
Gwenaëlle Morvan alors quelle est
l'histoire de cette association et bien
justement Denis le fondateur de
l'association
avait envie de changer les choses
durablement donc si je dis enfin si je
excusez-moi
donc en fait il voulait il donnait de
l'argent à une personne sans abri
régulièrement et il avait envie de
changer les choses durablement et il
s'est dit pourquoi pas avec des amis des
connaissances ce cotiser et acheter un
appartement à cette personne pour
changer sa vie durablement puisque c'est
quelqu'un qui le croisait tous les jours
et il se rendait compte que le fait de
lui donner une pièce voilà c'est c'est
pas qui l'aidait à sortir de cette
situation donc les objectifs justement
de l'association c'est ça c'est d'aider
les sans-abris à se loger pour pour
reconstruire finalement une vie voilà
donc le logement est effectivement un
outil mais le plus important c'est la
partie accompagnement accompagnement
donc par des professionnels mais aussi
l'accompagnement par des bénévoles pour
aider les personnes à tisser du lien
social et voilà le but c'est aussi de
les aider à se réinsérer dans le monde
donc à la fois dans le monde
professionnel mais aussi la dans la
société exactement donc c'est vrai que
le monde professionnel ça ça sera
vraiment dans un second temps nous on va
vraiment être axé sur
Passer partager des moments privilégiés
avec la personne lui donner envie de
rencontrer des personnes lui donner
envie de sortir de chez elle de faire
des activités ça peut être une activité
sportive une activité culturelle ou tout
simplement partager un café avec les
bénévoles sur votre site internet vous
insistez sur le terme de personnes en
situation de grande exclusion est-ce que
ça signifie alors en général les
personnes accueillies à toi à moi ont
[Musique]
à la rue ou ont eu un passage à la rue
après c'est vrai que le public est quand
même très varié on a des personnes qui
étaient tout à fait insérées et après un
accident de la vie qui se sont retrouvés
dans une situation précaire
mais effectivement ce sont des personnes
au moment de l'accueil souvent qui
dormait dehors ou encore dans une cage
d'escalier ou sous une tente voilà et
vous ne faites pas que loger ces
personnes vous les accompagnez vous
l'avez évoqué il y a un instant pour
pour se reconstruire quels sont les
accompagnements justement que que vous
proposez alors donc moi je suis traverse
sociale de formation et c'est vrai que
la particularité quand même à toi à moi
c'est qu'on accompagne un petit nombre
de personnes donc je pense qu'on peut
parler d'un accompagnement qualitatif
entre guillemets dans le sens où la
personne on va la rencontrer plusieurs
fois fois par semaine au début ensuite
au fur et à mesure de l'accompagnement
voilà les rencontres vont quand même
s'espacer mais on reste sur des
rencontres hebdomadaires
donc l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'accompagner la personne sur tous les
plans de sa vie sur les aspects qu'elle
souhaite elle travailler et en
partenariat bien sûr avec les acteurs
locaux on ne peut pas tout faire on ne
sait pas tout faire et c'est très
important de faire appel aux partenaires
locaux et comment se passe justement les
premiers échanges avec les personnes en
situation de grande exclusion car le
Conseil tel que de nombreuses personnes
ne connaissent pas les aides qu'ils
peuvent avoir ou même les associations
comme comme la vôtre qui peuvent leur
venir en aide votre première action
est-ce que c'est d'abord d'aller à leur
rencontre alors nous on s'appuie
vraiment justement sur les associations
qui sont en lien avec avec ses publics
donc on va s'appuyer par exemple sur le
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale on va
s'appuyer aussi sur des associations
spécialisés mais également des acteurs
comme la mission locale qui en lien avec
des publics jeunes fragilisés ou encore
des assistantes sociales de secteur
autre objectif celui d'acquérir des
appartements dans des quartiers
diversifiés qu'est-ce qu'on peut
qu'est-ce que peut pardon apporter aux
personnes ou là qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez pardon apporter aux personnes que
vous accompagnez d'être dans un
environnement plus sain moins anxiogène
peut-être que les foyers d'accueil par
exemple alors du coup moi j'ai travaillé
justement en centre d'hébergement
d'urgence donc la différence elle est
flagrante
le fait de réunir une même population
avec des problématiques
identiques dans un centre d'hébergement
forcément ça peut créer de la tension
des conflits entre les personnes
hébergées là quand les personnes
arrivent quand on leur remet les clés et
qu'elle visite l'appartement voilà
l'objectif c'est qu'elle puisse se
sentir chez elle donc c'est incomparable
voilà c'est les foyers ont leur utilité
mais c'est vrai que avoir son propre
appartement c'est quand même voilà on
donne un maximum de chances à la
personne pour pouvoir justement s'en
sortir et changer de vie les foyers de
toute façon sont tout de même positifs
bien entendu pour pour les sans-abris
malgré tout c'est une sorte de
sectarisation qu'ils ne veulent pas
toujours finalement et on le voit à
travers vos logements ils sont peut-être
même plus aptes à pouvoir se
reconstruire plus facilement dans un
environnement plus sain c'est ça c'est
cette idée là que vous défendez
exactement donc il faudrait on essaye
justement l'association toi à moi essaye
de développer des antennes c'est vrai
qu'en 2022 et 2023 il y a eu énormément
de nouvelles antennes et on a besoin du
soutien justement des particuliers
des pertes chacun peut faire quelque
chose donc ça peut être au niveau
financier effectivement on peut devenir
donateur mais on recherchait également
régulièrement des bénévoles on peut
abonner à de son temps ou tout
simplement on peut également partager
les informations partager l'action de
l'association on le disait vous vous
cherchez des logements à acquérir quel
type de logement justement
recherchez-vous en général et comment
est-ce que vous financez ces logements
c'est par rapport aux dons exactement
donc les logements sont financés par
rapport aux dons des particuliers
donc
en moyenne ce qu'on va ce qu'on va
demander c'est pour un logement on va on
va essayer d'avoir 100 par un si chaque
parrain s'engage à verser mensuellement
20 euros pendant une durée de 5 ans
voilà ça permet de financer
l'appartement et c'est ce qui nous
permet aussi d'être crédible devant la
banque et au niveau des appartements du
coup quels sont vos recherches alors
c'est vrai que suite aussi à des
contraintes budgétaires et puis par
rapport au profil des personnes qu'on
accueille en général c'est plutôt quand
même des deux pièces
donc là trial en tout cas c'est ces deux
pièces et l'objectif là pour le prochain
appartement voilà on se base également
sur un deux pièces en fonction du budget
peut-être qu'on pourra viser également
un trois pièces puisque il y a également
des familles qui se retrouvent à la rue
voilà c'était ma prochaine question
c'est le les publics finalement que vous
accueillez quand on parle de sans-abri
on se dit qu'il y a qu'une personne
malheureusement non parfois il y a juste
une mère et son enfant où il y a un père
et son enfant vous les accueillez
également alors c'est tout à fait
possible même dans un deux pièces quand
j'ai lancé la consultation c'est à dire
que je me suis adressée aux partenaires
pour qu'il m'oriente des candidatures
les deux pièces étaient ouverts
également à une famille monoparentale
avec un enfant donc effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
possible et dans les autres antennes il
y a des appartements plus grands
jusqu'au jusqu'au T4 donc il y a des
familles qui sont accueillies également
à toi à moi puisque c'est une réalité il
y a aussi des familles qui se retrouvent
à la rue on a parlé des logements de
l'accompagnement mais moins de la contre
l'exclusion qui est justement un autre
un autre point fort dans votre dans
votre association quelles sont les
actions mises en place pour intégrer ou
réintégrer les personnes que vous
accompagnez dans la société ou au sein
d'une collectivité par exemple alors par
exemple
on va travailler en partenariat avec la
Mission Locale pour que la personne
puisse se reprendre une formation se
qualifier en fait la particularité de
l'association c'est qu'il y a pas de
limite maximum donc on va vraiment
prendre le temps parce que l'objectif
c'est que la personne elle s'en sorte
durablement pour avoir travaillé dans
d'autres structures on est souvent
contraint à des à des échéances voilà on
peut faire un accueil pour six mois 12
mois maximum 24 mois là on a vraiment
pas de délai donc la personne peut se
permettre de se former si elle le
souhaite même pendant un an si c'est une
formation professionnelle qualifiante
qui va lui permettre de trouver un
emploi stable et en février vous avez
organisé une soirée ciné débat quel
était objectifs les objectifs derrière
cet événement alors justement augmenter
la visibilité de l'association en
Île-de-France on sait c'était un premier
objectif
à recruter alors c'est une réalité
recrutée entre guillemets de nouveau à
donata parrain ma reine
et pourquoi pas des bénévoles on a
certainement déjà trouvé de nouveaux
bénévoles grâce à cette action et puis
aussi on a lancé en même temps la
cagnotte pour le troisième appartement
donc il y a une cagnotte en ligne pour
financer l'achat du troisième
appartement même s'il est vrai qu'on a
déjà des subventions pour ce logement on
a besoin que ce soit complété par les
dons des particuliers et je le répète
chaque don compte quel que soit le
montant et on peut retrouver plus
d'informations sur votre site toi à
moi.net merci beaucoup Jane eiba Sako
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation de
genaba pardon Saco d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensation je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable de l'antenne toi moi
nord-ouest Île-de-France et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]